Again, a little further definition in existing market incumbents exists.
Customers can name the market. Customers want or need better performance.
And it's usually a technology-driven play.
Positioning is driven by the product and how much value customers place on its features.
The risks in an existing market is thinking that the incumbents are dumb.
Typically, incumbents unless they're large corporations that are falling asleep
will defend their turf and remember the network effects of an incumbent.
It might mean that it's not only about their product but it might be all the ancillary services
and third-party offerings they have in their catalog.
And remember, just as you're focused on innovation,
most incumbents are focused on innovation.
So before you jump into an existing market you need to take a look at the
innovation rate of the incumbents.
Now, one of the interesting things is trying to figure out what sales looked like
and what's the adoption rate in a new market.
It turns out one of the interesting curves for startup companies is a technology
lifecycle adoption curve popularized by Geoff Moore in a book called Crossing the Chasm.
And Moore postulated that there was a gap, a chasm, between visionaries and the mainstream
and pragmatic and conservative market.
It turns out though in an existing market that chasm between these early adopters and the mainstream
is very small or nonexistent because if you were right entering an existing market
your sales curve, the spreadsheet you're putting together for your revenue,
if you get it correctly should look just like this.
You're taking market share from incumbents from day one.
In an existing market, if customers react to your hypothesis that what they needed
was higher performance and you are correct, this is your revenue curve.
Congratulations!